i'd like to pull up this uh this tweet
from how do you say this guy's name
robert wright robert wright
oh man i think it's right is it is it
right right i'd like to call it this
tweet um this tweet from him in which he
basically copies a tweet from me from
seven years ago or whatever he says musk
and his apologists say if consumers
don't like what he does with twitter
they can go elsewhere but where else
would consumers go to post short
messages that can reach millions of
people other than twitter the free
market increasingly reflects the demands
of big money it's called platform
monopoly it's bad for our democracy as
well as our economy well you know what
robert to effing bad you've lost any
good faith response from me in this in
this effort because you and your ilk
have spent the entirety of the past six
years burning everything to the ground
spitting in the face of people who had
political disagreements with you and now
that you're poised to lose you think you
can come back and say oh this platform
monopoly is a big problem well that's
what i was saying what seven years ago
and now and now that you've come
crawling back i say this you don't get
to wage war and then once you start
losing or fear losing come and beg for a
ceasefire i'm not playing that elon musk
is going to be doing exactly what well
we're hoping that elon musk will do what
we've been hoping someone would do with
twitter and that is bring free speech so
you don't have to leave robert you get
to stay and say all of your dumb things
to everybody and we are not calling for
you to be banned we just want the rules
to be transparent we want people who are
suspended for bs fake reasons like carpe
donctum to be reinstated and you can go
cry about platform and monopoly
somewhere else because we've all been
and we've all been taking issue with
that for some time your your complaints
are duly noted and duly ignored
yeah does that article show his tweet
from like three years ago where he said
it's a private company it can do it at
once
yeah he said literally
how it started where it's going
no his tweet that everyone's
highlighting and they're pointing it out
as hypocritical he said that the people
complaining about the first amendment on
twitter failed to realize it's a private
company and they can do what they want
he's not wrong the first amendment is
pertaining to government restriction
however most people aren't saying the
first amendment if he wants to highlight
truly ignorant people who are
incorrectly saying the first amendment
by all means he can go and do that most
people who believe in free speech are
talking about the principle of free
speech one in which the first amendment
protects but exists outside of the
constitution the principle of free
speech is that we respect that other
people will say things we don't like in
the public discourse
twitter does not respect free speech
facebook youtube none of these platforms
do twitter used to web 1.0 was truly a
glorious time i just remember that oh
yeah web 1.0 yeah i don't know the lack
of self-awareness is astounding i mean
look i never exactly pictured him as the
kind of person who was really in touch
with what people who disagreed with him
or saying or thinking but you have to
have literally not heard a single thing
a conservative has said for the past
five years to make this point and think
you're saying anything be fair sheamus
if these people are only watching cnn of
course that's the case no exactly
exactly but to have a political platform
that large when you have no idea what
the other side is saying that's what
drives me that's the free speech the
term free speech it's like free speech
they don't it's like a buzzword it's
free free code big networks need free
code not free speech free speech who's
deciding the owner of the network you
can't tell them what to do i hear all
i'm saying is robert reich should be
more like me and know enough about his
opponent's position to make fun of them
in short form cartoons yeah what is it
about our intellectual class where they
get so much stuff so desperately wrong
exactly and this is what's so depressing
it's not as if we have an intellectual
class which is mediocre we have an
intellectual class which is stupid
they're dumb
they're really unintelligent do you
think they're affluent is it affluenza
affluenza i think it's pride i think
pride blinds people i think they have to
push a certain company line and they
doesn't matter how they lie or get stuff
wrong to achieve it there's just company
line you got to put out
and you got to stick with it and if you
stray from that company line you no
longer have a job well the question is
does he believe this
or is he just as you're saying trying to
tell the company line does he think it
would be an effective strategy because
my point is whether he believes it or
not to think that it's an effective
strategy to out yourself as a hypocrite
so blatantly
to me is bizarre come on they do it
every day yeah it's uh
something you learn about frauds they're
stupid and they're liars there's no
division there right rational people
have that division there are people
right now
that are complaining because al franken
basically was forced to resign in
disgrace over the photo where he was you
know grabbing that woman's chest and
they're complaining about this madison
cawthorne photo where he's got women's
lingerie on at a drinking on a cruise at
a party
and i can't remember who tweeted it but
they were like al franken was forced to
resign over something much less
salacious than this and it's like no he
wasn't he assaulted a woman like madison
hawthorne's in a chair drinking at a
party and doing silly things
call him say it's inappropriate fine
whatever it's a party but he didn't grab
and assault somebody and he's actually
representing most americans well so my
point is they're very awake women right
next to the point is that they're
they're creating this false hypocrisy
where they try and pull things up
they're like
this is hypocritical and it's like dude
robert reich tweeting this
which we all tweeted seven or eight
years ago
is absolutely absolutely astounding he
just one day came to realize truly these
people are vapid and devoid of any
curiosity they don't care what other
people think they make things up they
regurgitate them and that's why we
bought a billboard in times square with
special thanks to daily wire for helping
make it happen that says taylor loren's
doxxed libs of tick-tock because you
don't get to go on tv and just lie
without getting some pushback so that's
us pushing back even if it's a small
gesture yeah i like your war analogy
because it's kind of like being the
aggressor and attacking someone else and
as soon as they fight back you're like
all we are saying is give peace a chance
like dude you guys started this this is
no fault it's not it's not when you
fight back it's when they realize they
might lose yeah yeah they're like oh
wait you mean that guy picked a fight
with actually has is an mma fighter
actually do you guys see the joe rogan
episode with that mma guy
he said that he he got into politics
because he saw antifa beating up some
dude wow and he tried to pull him off
and they start fighting him
and he beat the crap out of him and then
they immediately backed off realizing he
had the power sounds like a right-wing
terrorist to me tim the left right now
is
fascistic they believe there is no truth
but power antifa uses violence against
people because they believe in using
violence to gain power when that mma guy
tried saving that dude and defended
himself and they realized he had more
power physically than they did they
retreated
no surprise there the convictions are
only as are as weak and flabby as their
little arms i'm surprised the local
district attorney didn't land the mma
fighter in prison seriously no and so
the left they're basically a metronome
and they very quickly go back and forth
between i'm very tough be scared of me
and oh i'm a poor sweet innocent little
victim someone come protect me mm-hmm
sounds like bipolar or someone that's
bipolar sounds like someone who's lying
to gain power
whatever gets them more power they do it
this right guy robert reich i remember
him being kind of vocal about hillary's
emails when that podesta emails dropped
you know 13 000 emails that they ended
up get trying to hide from the public 30
000.
and he was a big proponent of bernie
sanders at the time and was really
involved with the like the progressive
movement as it seemed like it might
actually function kind of what trump
picked up the reins of and then he went
full tds trump derangement syndrome and
in this hate of donald trump which is
like
it was just so
party politics like cult
thought so i thought reich was really
smart until that now i'm like i don't
know he's not wrong that social media
monopoly is dangerous reich wants big
government and big business whereas
trump felt like look just give people a
chance at a decent wage and you don't
need either
and that's where rice
basically if you don't have big
government in big business rice is out
of a job
yeah that's true i think what you'll see
often is
i'd be interested to see what happens
when the right if the right ever gets
institutional power will they become as
hypocritical or
will they just defend their side because
now they have the power and the ability
to wield it i kind of lean towards no
because
at least over the past eight or so years
the republicans have just sat on their
hands and said slow down their democrats
that's definitely true i would say if we
saw genuine conservatives real pro
family leaders take power
there would be corruption because that's
just always going to exist in any human
institution but i do believe it would be
much more structured and effective and
honest than anything we're seeing from a
left-wing authority structure because as
i've said before leftism is just a
synonym for social decay and they don't
have any real principles so people on
the right have genuine values that they
try to hold to and that they're
accountable to the left doesn't all they
have is the pursuit of power i think
it's a little broad to say leftism just
means social decay i disagree i think
there's a generational divide i think
modern leftism there's a reason boomer
is an insult this goes all the way back
to the boomer 60s and woodstock and and
the civil rights movement and all that
and you still see it like in my hometown
people are still waiting for that
you know civil rights movement to come
back and they're 70 80 years old you
know and it's just the younger
generations have had enough of it and
it's there's going to be you know it's
like a clash of the titans the new
generation is being born
is what we said earlier with new media
uh taking over legacy media and you see
these legacy media companies that just
don't get new media you know they'll pay
like hundreds of thousands of dollars
for somebody equally clueless about how
to go viral on new media when they can
hire the teenager down the street who's
got like a hundred thousand subscribers
or followers on instagram
i mean you take a look at chicken city
yeah more subscribers than cnn more
money than cnn well
they had 150 000 paying subscribers
on a 300 million dollar initial
investment up to a billion so probably
more profit but uh i honestly do think
that chicken city has made or at least
in the first 30 days on track to make
more money than cnn plus
no no no that that's that's that's not
true at all but my point is
bringing up chicken city is just because
i think it's hilarious how successful
it's become but uh you were mentioning
it before the show like none of these
people would ever thought won't think of
something like this how do you engage
community how do you you know you you've
got uh even even the even the daily
wires doing a really really great job
fighting back they're like we're going
to make a children's show and they are
still very much approaching this in a
traditional way with with new with new
technologies and the stuff we're working
on is trying to
be very different much more like a skunk
work or something chicken city was is a
wild and weird idea with chicken parties
but it's very much working in terms of
creating a new kind of family content
well part of why i would argue that it i
mean i imagine chicken city is more
profitable than cnn plus because you
have pun intended recouped your costs
cnn plus was house how much did you say
they invested 300 million
yeah so you're turning a profit on
chicken city right i mean look a chicken
rave is more interesting than a jake
tapper boat club in absolute terms i
mean the noises aren't all that
different
but
the chickens are more entertaining to
watch you're talking about the view yeah
everyone everyone keeps coming into
chicken city and saying is this the view
you're right about legacy media not
knowing what they're doing not only do
they not know what they're doing they
don't know who to talk to to figure out
what to do well i think is that it's not
like oh hey wait tim poole seems to
understand viral content let me reach
out and see if he can give me a referral
on how to advertise my whatever you want
yeah there's cognitive moment of
cognitive dissonance where it's like no
that can't be working even though they
see it working it's like that can't be
working it can't be working it takes
like two years before they're like oh we
were it takes never
something i learned about science it's
like the old generation never gets a
clue they just die away and the new
generation takes so what's happening is
we've seen that with like cbs abc that's
legacy legacy old golden age now we've
got this this modern legacy which is
like facebook youtube sorry guys um
twitter these centralized services
that's going the way of the dodo as well
it's moving towards federalization
federation and decentralization so
networks that aren't already focused on
that are also going to start falling
away you've seen facebook no but it's
even with the even with all the
political pressure for example like
rikita media when they did the kyle
rittenhouse case they like eclipsed any
of the big three networks in their
coverage because not only was it like
timely they got the feed but they had
intelligent analysis of it whereas the
legacy networks they did they were
caught with their pants not only that
but um
i believe for the johnny depp amber
heard trial right now
big news raketa law i think is the
number one super chatted channel in the
country this week
caught with their coverage of the johnny
depp and amber heard trump they were
great during the racism
i tuned in i was like i gotta know we've
been talking about johnny depp amber i'm
like i just gotta get a taste so i went
on and watched and it's it's john being
really funny and he's just making people
laugh that's why that thing's so popular
right now because he's hilarious wow
i'm missing out yeah i'm not gonna lie i
try not to pay attention to celebrities
but i did see a couple clips of him
responding to questions well the lawyer
was harassing him and it was genuinely
pretty funny yeah it's like some of the
best thing on tv right now yeah besides
this show yeah of course um
let's get them up the danger that these
uh these new legacy social networks have
is that they're centralized so like
the nsa can go into their database and
give them a gag order and then just take
control of the network so if you have
centralized services like logins and
passwords that's all legacy stuff man
liz i sent you my meme about finding the
feds in the data center i said when elon
musk inspects twitter that's what he's
gonna find uh we talked about who's
going to be on the ban list it's the
people in the past
yeah the people that are de-ranked and
don't know it all that's going to stop
that's what i'm saying that's my main
issue with twitter is like the people
who are interesting you just don't see
them and you have no idea why and they
don't have any idea why i wonder how
many people are going to go to prison
maybe it's a maybe it's a stretch to
assume
but i imagine
the testimony that we heard before
congress
was false
and elon musk is going to have documents
showing shadow banning and all that
stuff they claim they didn't do the
issue however is going to be that jack
dorsey is going to be like
well at the time
i didn't know that it was going on and i
was acting under the um the advisement
of our legal counsel
you know what they say the buck stops
with the legal counsel it's not my fault
elon musk and jack dorsey on this show
uh open invites would love to have you
be amazing i uh uh i hit up joe rogan i
was like you me elon jack dorsey twitter
uh twitter episode round two oh my god
but but you know
if whether something like that could
actually happen i kind of feel like i
once again just kind of like shoving
myself in there you have to wait for
elon to take over twitter and make
agreements with jack dorsey about what
he can and can't say sign the proper nda
and then you're gonna hear jack dorsey
unfettered it's so good i've been
planning a tech symposium with like
chris um at rumble bill ottman at mines
you know we got gab we got andrew torba
we got jeremy kaufman at odyssey there's
jack dorsey with twitter now elon can be
involved and he's a developer he's a
coder man this guy it's so great to have
him at the table right i think he bought
twitter so he could go
he's like i want to be in i read my mind
exactly yeah he can look at the
algorithms and figure out what's up
that's the exciting part
it'd be funny if like the only thing he
does is just tweet at some like
celebrity like sia or something and he's
like yo i would really love to meet you
and hang out and then afterwards he just
sells the company back
that's all i wanted to do like i didn't
know i know how to get a hold of this
person so
i do rich i am curious what his
long-term plans are he says he wants to
make it a more free speech i know his
long-term plan somebody was getting in
public again once he got way more no
he's not planning on take a look at this
tweet
we have this tweet from trung fun
hacker news speculating on how twitter
will integrate with spacex for
interplanetary communication someone
wrote this is from generalizations i'm
surprised no one has mentioned that
twitter is probably the best social
media platform for interplanetary
communication where low bandwidth and
delayed transmission are fundamental
bottlenecks and both limitations are
considered part of the appeal in that
case i wonder if the monetization will
ultimately be based on latency and
message size pay more for your message
to be sent from mars the next
transmission and pay more to send a
larger message locally i wonder if
twitter will be tied to starlink in some
fashion think about this elon musk
apparently
launched some shell companies and there
might be a single parent company for
spacex tesla and twitter
he might actually want to make sure
twitter works because it's the only
social media platform that would work
interp from through via interplanetary
communications facebook could
theoretically work
but you'd be limited this makes a really
really good point the appeal of twitter
is character limited limitations in
which case it's optimized for sending
messages back and forth can you send a
software update to the voyager craft to
tweet
yeah i was about to say i mean look if
if this gets hooked up to seti somehow
or aliens end up seeing twitter gigantic
trouble like this could really spell
disaster for the human race we sent out
voyager with that golden disc or
whatever with like basic math and
pictures of humans and then it's like
it's floating out there but what beats
it is the transmission of
at the speed of light of twitter
and so then one day
right right before the voyager craft
reaches alien vessel the wave
of twitter hits the ship and then they
see everything
i've never seen a thin person drink diet
coke they're like what is this
well the good the good news is all that
stuff gets scrambled after a certain
number of light years away uh but the
other one is imagine a mars rover that
life tweeted
that's highly practical
yeah i mean it's really easy to receive
transmissions and convert them to tweets
one of the things that uh a friend of
mine did was he had you could uh
i forgot you could use dial-up internet
to tweet and they did this really
interesting way where they converted the
the text into morse code morse code you
know that was then traveled over the
phone line
to uh voice to text which converted the
morse code back into text and then
tweeted it out crazy stuff like that
when when you had no means of like morse
code was the original twitter come on
mm-hmm
it's true yeah no people try to limit
their character account and i gotta say
though twitter really did disprove the
aphorism that brevity is the soul of wit
because it's all short and it's all the
dumbest thing you've ever read
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm we'll see you all there
you